you
hi everyone is Jerry this is game 3 from
the 2013 World Chess Championship match
between Anand and Carlsen going into
this round both players have one point
each and Carlsen on the white end opened
with Knight f3 as was the case in Game
one where he had white and we follow
that game all the way up to move 3 where
instead of Bishop g2 which was played in
Game one we have now c4 striking at the
black centre
Anand gives up his central pawn white
now having a two-to-one majority in the
center that's a good thing and in
exchange for it black hopes to get the
pieces out very quickly knowing now that
it will certainly take white some time
before the C pawn is recouped Queen a4
is played black blocks and develops
Bishop g2 Bishop g7 Knight c3 and you'll
know along the way there's never really
a moment to hang on to c4 successfully
case in point right here on move 6
firstly you never really want to
obstruct one of your central pawns
Bishop e6 does just that and it's also
vulnerable to Knight g5 kicking away the
defender of C form so Bishop e6 not a
good idea but maybe now that II five is
played and the Queen is there to defend
g5 maybe now black is ready to defend c4
successfully and so you need to maybe be
careful if you go with the routine moves
such as castle now what are you going to
do as white to gain that pawn back well
you could still play Knight g5 and if
the knight is captured you're there to
smash through on the black position on
c6 so it seems like the Queen is there
but it's just it's not working out
there's a tactical issue on the c6
square so white could have castled at
this point I move seven but Carlsen
picks up the pawn right away Knight on G
to e7 the more natural square is usually
f6 for that King Knight there's maybe a
couple reasons behind deploying the
knight to e7
one is that the bishop would like to
have more direct sight of d4 black would
like to post up on that square has
support on d4 and maybe the night on e 7
would like to pivot about by way of f5
and jump into D form white castles
black castles and now d3 age six and
this is to secure an eventual Bishop's
position on e6 Bishop d2 tame deployment
for that Queen Bishop it's clearing c1
for a white rook one other thing that I
had question on the white side is what
if instead of Bishop d2 you swing the
Queen over and converge on h7 or h6 one
reply that black would always have just
to point out very quickly is Knight to
f5 and this is super convenient Knight
may very well I've wanted to go there
anyway and now it comes with an attack
on the Queen and soon enough he'll be
taking up a nice residence on d4 so
there's never really a problem with
meeting this Queen to h4 move Knight f5
is there but one thing to certainly shy
away from is a move such as g5 you're
setting yourself up for some vicious
attack where the sacrifice can take
place on g5 white can give up their dark
square bishop and now look for me on h7
it can be defended temporarily with
Bishop to f5 but what do we do now if
white tries to remove that Bishop from
f5 remove the defender of h7 black can
reinforce this point knowing that if it
is captured you can recapture and if
this well now you're actually just as
black making that last move you're
bringing more white pieces into the
attack and what to do about Queen h7 not
really a good defense if the rook runs
away and I can actually jump into f6 if
he's captured this is going to be a
meeting too and if he's not captured
it's a main one some other lines may
very well run Queen d7 again preparing
to meet Bishop takes with Queen takes
and the Queen is there to save the day
but what do you do now is black if g4 is
played similar story take here
the knight is brought in to play same
stuff going on with the knight f6 queen
h7 to f7 ideas or maybe mate you get the
idea and one last variation would be
after this capture if the rook runs away
to e8 we could give a check we could
come back here look for main on f7 then
that can interfere with that like it
hammer away at f7 black is there to
defend but now it comes in another
Knight into the attack this Bishop is
immune from capture you'll know due to
this check now the king is flushed to a
square where a knight could now give a
fork to the Queen and King Bishop takes
Knight takes maybe there was even
something better along the way but at
the very least you're getting that black
Queen so just some things to be aware of
that sacrifice is really crying out
bishop takes on g5 if g5 is in fact
played but we didn't even have Queen to
h4 we had the tame Bishop d2 the knight
takes up a nice post on d4 to eliminate
it and with that we have now a
structural change keep in mind that this
is the correct way to be recapturing
after Knight takes you don't want to
take with the Queen not only for the
reason that you would lose this pond but
let's just say for some reason you
couldn't take on c7 successfully it's
still not a good idea because in this
endgame I'm not so sure that this d4
pawn is an asset it is much the opposite
to liability has pressure on it and this
Knight is very active and there will
soon be additional pressure along the C
file so if you're going to have this
space advantage you'll want to keep the
Queen's around on the board
so that's what black does capturing
immediately with the EEP on the night
jumps into e4 looking to put pressure on
the black Queen side b7 comes to mind
the bishop is certainly there and the
knight will look to put pressure on c5
or so I thought
the knight never really ends up on that
c5 square though c6 immediately blunts
this diagonal and now we have Bishop to
b4 so now initially I thought Knight to
c5 but maybe there's some thoughts of
Knight to d6 that also comes to mind
so Bishop e6 the queen is hit she drops
all the way back and during the game I
was certainly scratching my head as to
why queen c1 was played and my thoughts
ran as well maybe it had to do with the
where if the bishop is threatened with a
5 the Bishop could come back here and at
the very least white is grabbing a tempo
against the h6 point but we didn't have
that the idea really is for the Queen to
later as we will see she relocates to
the f4 square I must say that c2 seems
like the more natural square you would
like to keep seat c1 available for rook
but the Queen again has some intention
of deploying over here on the Kings side
so Bishop d6 opposite the the better
Bishop I guess you could say I don't
know that the e6 Bishop is better than
the the g1 Bishop may be trying to
exchange these and then take up a nice
home for the knight on d5 would be a
good idea
so Bishop d5 it is and now we have a 4 I
was also scratching my head with this
move not really being able to make much
sense of it during the game but it does
show itself very soon what the idea is
behind it white is anticipating at this
point anons idea of shutting down this
Bishop with b6 and c5 and if b6 is going
to be played and
is we eventually will be able to peel
open the a file or at the very least
challenge the pun on b6 with this a5
move so Carlson gives up this dark
square bishop as otherwise he's going to
be shut down
he's going to be knocked right out of
the game just making a passing move if
rook e1 what exactly is this Bishop
doing and look at the great position on
the black side a very strong very
healthy pawn structure this Bishop
biting on a rock soon this rook will be
activated and black is certainly in the
driver's seat so now is the time to
understand that your Bishop could be
running the risk of not contributing at
all in the position so let's at least
exchange that Bishop Queen is there to
recapture and now comes a five this is
of course consistent with that a4 move
from a couple turns ago rook to b8 rook
to e1 defending e - and you might have
thought actually at this point there's
an opportunity to pick up this pawn on e
- with f5 and this could be an
interesting variation Knight d2 and if
Bishop takes King takes what's going to
happen now after Queen takes e - well
what can follow is a takes ba takes
being rook takes rook rook takes rook
and during this game I was thinking the
Queen could take on c6 and she could but
what's maybe better is to first make use
of the temporarily the temporary
position of the Queen on c1 getting the
rook involved with the tempo on the
Queen and only after Queen takes D can
we have Queen takes on c6 note I'm here
to take the knight the rook is
threatened with check and just making a
passing move you note that white is
super active and a move like this can be
met with Queen takes on g6 note that
this night is still immune from capture
due to white getting to this
Frank and there's big problems here for
black so just one thing to note that was
the first thing that came to mind for me
whoa is there a way to kick the night
away and pick up this pond well not so
fast the other thing you'll want to be
cautious of as black is ever touching
this F pond you really are subjecting
your King to some issue on your seventh
rank so it's rook to be a rookie one now
blacks other rut gets involved takes
takes and now here comes Queen f4 so
we're seeing the reason a few moves
prior why we're having Queen to c1 she
is now contributing in some way on the
Kings side
RUP to d8 and now we have h4 securing
the g5 Square rook to d8 by the way is
to maybe prevent this Knight from
jumping into d6 that could maybe be a
bit problematic so it rules that out
right away h4 is played King to h7 black
might be wanting to make a move like
Bishop e5 but that would drop h6 King h7
is now there to defend Knight d2 and
when I saw this move I was thinking
during the game that we could yet again
see the game end with a three-fold
repetition I started to get very
concerned didn't want to see that and I
thought that that's what we would enter
I thought that at this point black had
an opportunity to force a three-fold
repetition in the following way after
Queen g4 I thought instead of h5 black
could play here and there aren't any
there are very many options for the
white queen you play here it's this sort
of stuff and one other try might be well
Queen here same story
fortunately for white there would be a
way around having this game go into a
threefold repetition a move that I
overlooked which is e for this may very
well be a good reply at this point if it
is taken now maybe
some issue for the black side having to
now work out of a pin so we didn't go
down that road but we did get to the
point where the bishop did play to e5
and the Queen does play to g4 and now
with h5 the queen is being kicked all
the way to the corner and she stays
there for a while about ten moves there
is pressure on c6 and the idea should
certainly be for white to somehow
activate the Queen who's now stuck in
the corner very unique position to see
the Queen in the corner and as where
where might there be some compensation
what are what are some good things that
White has at least well at least there's
this rook activity if the Queen if the
black Queen goes too far this rook could
make use of the a7 square this Knight is
also keep in mind by having this h5 move
played the knight is not long off from
being able to make use of g5 so there's
some there's some negatives associated
with the black position I guess you
could say the Queen sure was kicked into
the corner but black had to give some
squares up or a square up in order to do
so g5 in particular so it is c5 the
black pawns are set into motion and
there is this idea not long off which is
soon to be creating a past pun a past C
pun so Nike for King g7 Knight g5 the
bishop is hit and now the big decision
is do you try to hang on to your bishop
keep in mind that this is immediately
challenged with rook a3 and if the
bishop is playing to f5 or g4 we can
have Bishop h3 this is fine white would
love to have the light square Bishop
Soph the board and on top of it the
queen is finally seeing so we didn't
have that anon enters a position where
we have opposite color bishops this
bishop will be taken in short order but
what is played
right now is III a lot of time was
invested on that particular move about
12 minutes it was uh it did get a little
bit close before time control here both
players running a little bit short on
time nothing too too serious but at this
moment we do now have a structural
change with III opening the position up
whereas for black who has the bishop
pair and we have captures captures and
now Bishop to d4 this is an important
point in the game because I believe that
this pawn can be captured successfully
it may seem a bit scary to do so because
there certainly will be a lot of
pressure now placed on the e6 Bishop
hitting it's already hit twice and it
will now be hit a third time but black
is there to defend and if more pressure
is placed on it black is there to still
defend some more and there may also be
first a move like this which is a good
idea kicking the rook back and then this
type of move everything seems to be held
together and I don't know how
inconvenience the black pieces would
really be having the rooks function on
this sixth-ranked and keep in mind this
isn't just any pawn that black would
have been would have been picking up on
b2 without the white beep on around
blacks beep on increases in value and
the rook is very well placed here on b6
to support each ensuing advance it's
passed and it will be pushed in short
order so this is maybe a direction that
Anand could have gone in to have
captured on b2 right now but instead it
was Bishop deform the rook drops back c4
challenging d3 if this pawn is ever
captured you're helping this rook come
to life so we don't have that particular
capture we don't have D take C so what
do we have we have Knight takes e4
the
lack structure here and with the
opposite color Bishop ending white will
look to put pressure on this base point
g6 so the bishop gets there right away
the queen is now finally ready to come
out from the corner C takes D and not so
fast with Bishop takes D if Bishop takes
we could have this and I'm not so sure
what is even best it might turn out best
that the King has to come out to
recapture so that when the rook does
take on d3 the King is at least there to
defend g3 but we're in a position now
where black is up upon their King is
exposed and it's really not a road to go
down
Queen c6 I don't even want to go any
further down this line black is the
better side here again up upon and a
little bit safer King so we don't
capture on d3 with the bishop instead it
was Bishop rook to d2 that was played
and now the Queen swings in to be for
hitting the rook pressure on b2 and we
had rook to a rook on a to d1 more
pressure on d3 this is also one other
possibility that black had which is to
say rook to f8 and now there's some
issue on f2 for example if let's say
this pawn is captured black can actually
smashed through on f2 and then hammer
away at that square with rook here or
maybe even better it is Queen to d6 a
couple ideas in mind this rook is pinned
it's going nowhere Queen takes here as a
threat and also Bishop takes on f2 as a
threat unleashing a discovered attack on
the bishop on d3 so we could have this
and after Queen let's say to g3 to
defend our Queen to g2 to defend g3 keep
in mind you wouldn't want to play here
that's running into more trouble with
that f2 rook so Queen to g2 to defend
now this rook comes over more pressure
on f2 black is just firing away at this
rook which is pinned
and finally can capture away on that
square and at the end of it black is yet
again up upon in this Queen endgame and
it is black who's the one who's trying
to of course win we did not go down that
line we did not have this particular
move played it was not rook to f8
putting pressure on f2 but Queen to b4
certainly an active move but I believe
this would have been better I've got an
A to D one it was Bishop takes pawn the
Queen is finally out and about and after
Bishop to f6 black is essentially just
crawling into a ball and trying to make
sure they neutralize the position black
still being the side who is up upon but
this Bishop is very strong on e4 and
black has some concern about white being
able to converge on the g6 pawn
Bishop f6 was it and another idea would
be
with the idea of shutting down the rooks
influence on the D file since there is
now a nice strong link on the the d4
post but it was not e5 that was played I
guess one thing to know is that if we do
have a five I guess I guess the only
concern is that maybe this Bishop could
be undermined at some point with f4
that's going to however take some work
to do just that we didn't have that it
was Bishop f6 white now captures on d3 a
lot of exchanges looking to now
penetrate on that seventh rank that is
neutralized a lot of pieces now being
exchanged we're in an opposite color
Bishop ending and after Bishop d3
keeping pressure on the pond also paving
the way for Queen to b7 to pick up the
b5 pawn and on says go ahead take it I
want to make sure that I have my King
safe I want to make sure I have secured
my g6 point and there's really at this
point no way to break down the black
position
Black has the more exposed King but at
the end of the day this is going to turn
out to be a drop however you slice it
but certainly a fighting draw in this
particular game and this one here
finishing up where we have simply no
mating material so much more interesting
game that we saw here Anand's really
having a stronger pull throughout a
great portion of this game from couple
ways that he could have may be improved
upon his moves but at the end of the day
where once again seeing a drop but yet
but excuse me a fighting drop I should
say in this particular round of the
World Championship so we're still tied
now at one and a half points each and
we'll see what takes place in round four
so that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it
take care
you